Ian: Hi I'm Ian Bremmer, president of Eurasia
group here at the World Economic forum in
Davos
I think 2008 is the year when the United States
is going to be increasingly challenged in
terms of the insecurity that its people feel
about to what extent the trajectory the world
is heading is the one that is beneficial to
the United States.
So I think if there's one thing that the world
can do together, it is both to help Americans
understand that globalization is -- supporting
globalization -- a leadership role in globalization
is something that continues to be important
for the world.
And also that the world, that other states,
that emerging markets need to cooperate constructively
with the United States in that fashion.
I think never in the course of a globalized
world has the direction of leadership been
so challenged as in 2008.
The confluence of the economic challenges
that are presently being faced with Beijing
Olympics and with an American presidential
election coming in November is unfortunate
in many ways,
and challenges a lot of the values that are
shared by the members of the World Economic
forum in Davos.
I think those values need to be spoken loudly
and particularly this year.
So I think if there is anything that folks
in the world can do, it's to support that.
Thank you very much.